♪ I'll treat you right.
(Upbeat music)
- Well, season two of PubLIZity
is, like, a very exciting
thing because, like, a
number of things happen.
- Correct and, like,
the things about me
are, like, probably
the most amazing.
And you can expect that
I will be expecting.
- Yeah, Liz, as unavailable
as she is to say, is pregnant.
Wait, you're---
- I'm pregnant.
(apprehensive music)
- What?
- Liz, I've told
you, like, a lot.
- No, I'm thrilled for
you, like, that's amazing.
- No, like, you're
my best friend.
- You're, like, my best friend.
Like, I'm obviously, like,
super-thrilled for you, but--
- Thank you, I'll
leave it at that.
I'm keeping it this time.
- Amazing.
(upbeat music)
- She's, like, amazing.
She's, like, my
best friend in ever.
I wouldn't want to spend,
like, my professional,
or personal, or television life.
Which is all the same
thing at this point,
with anybody else.
She's so amazing.
Uhummmazing....
(squeaking noises)
like, anyway,
but it's like she can be
really difficult, too.
- That's not true.
- I think I could probably
do a much better job
of taking care of
your an-ne-ce-tees,
or your own baby, or
this business than
you ever could.
- Like I'm going to
take my own advice and
I'm going to, like, go to bed.
And that's what you're left
with, so I'm storming out.
(melodramatic music)
(upbeat music)
- She's, like, an
amazing person--
- Liz, you have to
incorporate your question
in your sentence.
- For who?
- For everyone in the audience.
- Oh, all right,
I'm sorry, wait...
Can you repeat the question?
- What is your favorite
thing about working with me?
- Oh my God, she's
an amazing person.
And, like, a role model,
like, for other women
and, like, honestly at
this point, like, for women
like, she's a front-runner.
Like, she's gonna get
the job done in like--
- Seriously, stop it.
- I can't stop, Liz,
cause you make me go, go, go.
Like, you inspire me.
- You're not going
to make me cry
in front of this whole
electronic press kit?
- You're my best friend.
- Like, Liz, you're
my best friend.
- I just, like,
love you so much.
- I love you too, Liz.
- But anyways, for me it's
like she loves to have fun.
- I do and, like, honestly,
I throw up in a bucket,
like, in our office, constantly.
And, like, Liz is,
like, brave about it.
I just keep throwing up.
- Are you sure that's
not some guy's--
- What?
- [Narrator] Kroll
Show, all new episodes
Tuesdays at 10:30.
(electronic music)